merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la santé le 8
février dernier s'est tenue au sénat la
7e édition du colloque faste organisé
par l'association imagine fort margot
est consacrée au cancer de l'enfant
ce fut une journée dense et porteuse
d'espoir car en effet les choses bougent
en matière de dons cologie pédiatrique
notamment au niveau de l'innovation et
de la recherche alors il y a eu des
améliorations je pense notamment à
l'action de l' agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament mais des freins
demeurent et l'un d'entre eux est celui
de l'évaluation après que l'agencé
européenne de du médicament est donné
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
d'un médicament innovant il y à une
procédure d'évaluation par la haute
autorité de santé
or cette procédure d'évaluation n'est
plus adapté aux médicaments innovants
notamment ceux destinés aux enfants en
matière par exemple de thérapie de
thérapie génique ou de médecine de
précision une réforme de l'évaluation
avait été annoncé nous mêmes eaux lors
du dernier projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale nous avions
déposé au nom de la commission un
amendement en ce sens mais qui n'a pu
être discuté du fait du contexte
particulier du dernier plfss
donc ma question est simple où en êtes
vous sur cette réforme